[Music]
[Applause]
last year allah tested me severely i had
a near-death experience i suffered from
a rare case of pulmonary embolism as i
lay there in the hospital bed lungs full
of blood clots contemplating what could
potentially be my final moments i feared
the worst it was not so much death that
i feared it was my preparation for it i
was not able to take advantage of the
countless opportunities allah had
presented before me i haven't achieved
all my goals was i ever going to achieve
them this was my opportunity to be more
focused and turn to allah and work
harder in fact this operational year was
one of the most productive of my life
but i didn't do it alone the institute
that i co-founded sapiens institute has
been instrumental to this success
teamwork makes the dream work i
completed my master's in applied
theology at the university of oxford
started my phd in the philosophy of
religion wrote my fourth book the burhan
arguments for a necessary being i had a
deep thought-provoking discussion with
famous clinical psychologist jordan
peterson which has now garnered over 2.2
million views i also contributed to one
of the largest online video libraries
addressing the many doubts
misconceptions about islam and much more
i am blessed to be part of this
hard-working and wonderful team who have
also achieved many great things this
year these achievements could not have
been possible without allah's help and
the team at sapiens institute and your
support who knows if this will be my
last ramadan who knows if this will be
your last ramadan you have the
opportunity to gain the immense reward
by helping us create support and develop
a new generation of people to
intellectually and academically share
islam click the button or go to the link
below and donate now do not miss this
opportunity
[Music]
you